i love you tell the boys i love them
and i love the boys too so the show is
back to give us that friday feeling
and the latest episode has an absolutely
insane amount of easter eggs in it
throughout this video we're going to be
going through the entire thing and
breaking it all down
so if you want to know the ins and outs
as well as our theories then this is the
video for you
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out the latest entry yet then i
highly recommend that you turn off now
we will be covering some of the plot
points from the comics so it's probably
best to just dive out the video if you
feel like something could be ruined
if you're still here thank you for
clicking this as always this is the
heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul now let's get into
the boys
okay so we opened eight years ago with
frenchie in his apartment with his
friend cherie and jay
sheree has been popping in and out
throughout the season and we learn why
they sort of have a strained
relationship as frenchie has to
basically choose between his duty or his
friends at one point
we see frenchie develop a xanax filled
gas canister which he uses to rob a bank
with
and not long after he's picked up by the
cia namely colonel mallory
in this episode we start to learn minor
elements about her past
and get more information on the death of
her grandchildren which happened at the
hands of lamplighter
in the first season we discover that
this made her move to the country
and the character comes face to face
with him at the end of the episode
which we'll get into in just a bit we
then jump to the present
where frenchie is cutting out the
tracking device from annie's neck
i kinda got a lot of suicide squad vibes
from this and with it removed she's now
able to go incognito there's a hilarious
running gag throughout the entry in
which ashley keeps asking where she
is and this being taken out of her
allows her to go to the sage grove
hospital
which is a medical facility designed
specifically for fine-tuning compound b
what you really care about though is the
two lovebirds
and how we left them last time the first
time we see homelander in stormfront
they're apprehending a criminal in a
back alley they end up crushing his
skull
and i love how they complain about cell
phones stopping them doing their job
last week homelander was of course
caught on camera killing an innocent
bystander
and this ruined his reputation he
clearly doesn't care about it though
and he's happy just continuing how he
has been
stormfront and homelander get it on and
even smear their victims blood in their
mouth as they kiss
i actually think that this is a minor
nod to the comics in which huey went
down on annie at one point
and ended up getting blood around his
mouth maybe
maybe that's a reach anyway throughout
stormfront and homelander
really developed their relationship and
we actually
finally learned the truth about her for
weeks now we've been theorizing that she
was created in germany by frederick ward
after he experimented on humans we
initially thought that her mother might
have been a jewish civilian
that was taken into one of the camps
however we discovered that stormfront
was actually married to vort
and that she was in deep with the german
forces in the comics
vort was their top scientist and he
created compound v with vogelbaum during
the war they defected
and fled to america which is where they
continued their work
stormfront was actually the first person
to ever successfully take to v
and after arriving in the us she started
to masquerade as the hero liberty
before going into hiding because of the
murder that she carried out in the 70s
i always kind of wondered why liberty
was allowed to lie low
and then return years later but it
becomes clear that due to her marriage
to vote that she could pretty much do
whatever she wanted to
the villains in this world either tend
to have superpowers
or corporate ones but with stormfront
having both
she's definitely not someone to be
reckoned with it seems that
in her time out of the spotlight she
raised a daughter named chloe which is
the woman that we saw in the photograph
last week
i was so glad that came true because we
finally got a theory right
there were certain clues that gave away
her german descent
such as the name adele which is actually
german and i think this might be
stonefront's real name
i was not expecting it to go this deep
though and it gets pretty crazy
just how embedded she was with fort and
the reich we learned that stormfront has
been running the sage grove hospital
in order to refine compound v so that
she can build an army of supermen
through this subsidiary of wart i
believe that she wants to make it seem
that the super terrorist threat is so
severe
that the public will willingly hand over
power to her in the seven
this will allow her to take over the
world and thus she can
remake it in her image hitler of course
wanted to create his own master race
and i actually have a theory that
stormfront wishes to do the same thing
with her and homeland as child
homelander is a blonde head blue-eyed
superman
and his aryan features would be highly
desired by stormfront
who would have been brought up to
believe that this was the height of
humanity
i think that her end goal is to become
pregnant with his kid so that she has a
new suit weapon
that embodies her beliefs through vote
surveillance of the character
and ryan she likely knows that
homelander won't kill someone that's
attached to his child
and thus even if he did turn against her
he would likely allow her to live
because she's looking after their
offspring
this is of course similar to becca i
think that there are little clues here
and there that tease how everything's
gonna go
it's the only reason i can think why she
would let him almost choke her
and still continue to get close to him
but yeah
love does work in mysterious ways now we
also learned that when v is injected
into infants
it often works but when it's injected
into adults it's pretty much potluck
stormfront wants to stabilize it so that
anytime you inject it into an adult
you get a solid result and i think this
teases two things
now in the comics the boys themselves
used v to fight the supes
and it is likely that the further we get
into the series they will be calling
upon this to aid them in their fight
secondly it also explains why stormfront
doesn't age
as we know homelander was injected as a
baby and he aged normally
however stormfront has remained at the
same age and it is possible that because
she was injected with it as an adult
she has not grown at all those are our
main theories anyway
so make sure you drop them below if you
have any others
now thematically this episode is about
the past and the secrets of it being
brought to the forefront
this is not only shown in stormfront but
also frenchy
lamplighter and most of the major
characters in the entry
there's a hilarious bit when homelander
wants to show stormfront some flowers
that he's brought for her
but she says she has to go to vault
tower for 20 minutes
he'll last far longer and he gets tired
of waiting and
sets the trailer alight which this at
least he didn't crush anyone's head this
time i suppose now
he once more becomes my favorite
character and watching him say that he
needs to practice lines with black noir
is
extra hilarious to me especially because
we know that the characters are mute
and he sees the boys lair for the first
time and she doesn't exactly get the
warmest of welcomes from billy
who has to tackle with the fact that
she's a soup something that he's come to
hate over the past decade
also starlight don't you just light up a
room
nice pun there now billy even puts her
in his scopes at one point
i think that him being accepting of
annie in this episode
does tease that down the line he might
be more open to working with the supes
to take down the corporation
huey also wears a billy joel t-shirt
with his album cover from the stranger
on it
i think there's been a dual easter egg
in almost every episode so far
and it's nice that they keep up the
tradition with this little nod after
learning about the hospital last week
annie gives the boys the location and
they investigate it to find out what's
going on
we cut to maeve i love how they've
already made a brave made pride bar
i think this is really speaking to how
corporations and politicians will
proudly support rainbow flags on their
apps and profile pictures
in order to make it seem like they
support the gay community
then they'll turn around and vote down
their right to marriage
it's visual signaling at its finest and
maeve just seems completely deflated
however a ray of hope comes in with the
deep who
through some halibut has found a camera
that was on board the plane from the
first season
although it was hilarious out the deep
had to put some feelers out into the
ocean
and again it feels like the show is
riffing on justice league as
batman suggested that to aquaman in the
film the plane crash was obviously one
of the most shocking scenes in the first
season
and its exposure would of course bring
homelanders image completely crashing
down i actually think that maeve will
take this footage to homelander
and attempt to blackmail him in order to
escape the seven
she even says that she could release it
to cnn if he doesn't agree with her
and it's hinting at what's ahead now if
you don't want anything from the comics
ruined then i recommend that you skip
ahead about 40 seconds
as we will be discussing one of the big
plot elements involving maeve
in the comics maeve actually ended up
turning against homelander
and she bugged the seven's headquarters
so that the boys could spy on them
maeve met her demise after she tried to
kill him with a sword
however as this was just a prop it
didn't work
and homelander killed her i do think
that something similar will likely
happen with her in the show
and she's gone on a really interesting
arc throughout the series
that sadly can only really go one way
now on the set of the seven
the deep bumps into a train and he
sympathizes with him being kicked out of
the group two
he's clearly trying to recruit him to
the church of the collective and even
offers him a can of fresca
if you checked out our last video then
you'll know we think that this is
drugged
and it's used by the church to sedate
people and get them to be more
suggestible
so that they can recruit them we
actually see the church's leader alistar
adana
once more later in the episode and he's
even serving it for dinner
whenever the case is though they are
clearly riffing on scientology
the church is often criticized for
recruiting high-caliber celebrities
and the collective seems to go after
disgraced soups a train even mentioned
seeing the documentary about them
which does seem to be a nod to the one
about scientology
the church knows the ins and outs of a
train's life and with stormfront being a
member at one point
it does seem like they're also part of
war ii alistar also mentioned
shockwave becoming the next a-train and
that war are allowed to do this
because it's a trademark i think this is
a little nod to comic books in general
which often have sidekick mantles passed
on from character to character
i mean i mean there's there's been about
seven robins at this point
now alistair promises to get a train
back into the seven but clearly
he's gonna have to do something we then
jump to the sage grove center
and i love how kimiko has a little bossy
knuckle duster
she clearly is a boss too as she refuses
to pretend to be the patient on a
stretcher
so frenchie has to do it instead the
hospital is absolutely packed with
easter eggs
and there are a couple of patients in it
that pull directly from the comics
now firstly is love sausage and mother's
milk actually calls him this
and in the source material that's also
the guy's moniker
the russian soup first appears in the
first volume of the comics
and he gets his name for his his well
you know what it is now
he even chokes mother's milk out at one
point and i bet it's not the first
person to have choked on that one either
huh you're having that there's also a
miniature character that could be
riffing on ant-man as well
i don't know if it's just the bad
picture quality that i had
but i think his skin actually made him
look a lot like jack from jupiter
but yeah let me know if i'm wrong i'll
have re-watched the episode by now
properly but yeah
these early screeners to send you 480p
most the time
now it's here that they see lamplighter
for the first time and he's a far cry
from the comics
in the original work the first time that
we encounter him
he's actually a zombie turns out that
compound b
fires up your brain even in death and
after a supers killed
vort tend to still use them for br to
make it seem like they're okay
before fully retiring them landlighter
is someone that's gone through this
process
and he's unveiled in a pretty horrendous
state crawling around in his own feces
and mumbling about his fire it's really
messed up and who knows they might even
end up going the same way with this
version down the line
i did actually think that he might be a
patient but it turns out that he's just
one of the staff
he also has no qualms about killing
those that come in
and we learned that one of the patients
was suicidal so it does seem that vaude
has set this up as a psychiatric
hospital
in order to get access to subjects the
casting of sean ashmore is inspired
as he was of course iceman in the x-men
movies but they've kind of switched it
up here to make him more in line with
pyro
frenchie and coast stuff this stretchy
with hard drives but when frenchie and
lamplighter come face to face
things go to hell with the patience
being set free
i don't know why cindy just didn't crush
the door and escape anyway but
she's clearly gonna become a wild card
at some point in the series
now due to the devastation that cindy
leaves behind i think it becomes clear
that she was the character that killed
rainer
she explodes several heads and it's
likely that stormfront has been sedating
her and then bringing her out for
missions
she's completely overpowered and it
looks like she's gonna easily take out
anyone that she comes across
to make matters worse one of the escape
patients comes across billy
and co outside and he freaks out badly
injuring huey
this leaves frenchie mother's milk and
chemical caught
out with no cover they have to navigate
through the hospital
lamplighter and the group end up working
together in this entry and we also learn
about his and frenchy shared past
now i think that this was written kind
of weirdly and i've even spoken to
people who've also seen the episode and
didn't really know what was going on
it's a bit difficult to follow at first
but the way that i took it was that the
cia
had blackmail material on lamplight air
that they would release to the public
unless he helped them spy on vote
lamplighter didn't go through with this
and frenchy tailed him before getting
the call about his friend jay's overdose
he fled to help him out and in this time
lamplighter went to mallory's house
where he mistakenly killed her
grandchildren it seems that lamplighter
had a guilty conscience over this
and he relocated out of the spotlight
and joined the hospital to burn the
evidence left behind by boat
again if i'm wrong my bad but it does
feel a bit all over the place now billy
annie and huey attempt to commandeer a
passerby's vehicle
and he pulls a gun on them which makes
starlight zap him
she sucks the power from his car to
cauterize huey's wound
and they flee to a hospital frenchy
makes a knockout canister like how he
witnessed in the opening
but cindy quickly disposes of it luckily
they're saved by stormfront
who's returned to see what's going on at
the hospital they sneak out and frenchie
apologizes to kimako for trying to save
her
even though she never asked for it it's
good to see them
actually on speaking terms again well
not speaking terms but
you know what we mean and mallory
arrives to see lamplighter
now clearly they're gonna be using him
to spy on the seven
like how he should have done in the
first place our first look at the
character in the marketing material for
the show
showed him at the seven's headquarters
so it does look like he will be going
back there
and collecting intel on them in the
comics we learned that mallory actually
shot lamplighter before the events of
the first graphic novel
and this is the person who left him in a
zombie-like state
i love that they kind of tease that here
but i i do think they're going in a
different direction
i think it's going to be great that
they've got another soup in their ranks
and it's really going to be interesting
to see whether they make his character
follow the comics or not
at stonefront's room we also see that
there's scaffolding in
after she and homeland are completely
wrecked it last week
and it's here that she reveals the truth
about her past she offers homelander the
position of being leader of her new
world
though as i said i think something else
will be going on here
the episode ends with cindy hitchhiking
and she gets into a car
now what could be happening next week
well with cindy's release
it also brings exposure to what vorde
have been doing
she pretty much represents their dirty
little secret
and her getting out blows everything out
in the open
to make matters worse she's also
extremely powerful
and though stormfront has attacked her
she survived
showing that the most powerful soup in
the seven still has difficulty taking
her down
actually thinking that she's heading to
vault right now and will be trying to
take the company out
however the seven will win and such a
large-scale attack will give them the
ability to promote the supervillain
problem
even more stormfront will be able to
state that they really need to bring in
more supes to protect the public
and this attack will enable her to
slowly start to build her army
anyway that closes out the episode and
as always i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it so comment below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our other breakdowns in the series
which are gonna be linked at the end
don't forget we're also giving away a
free copy of the christopher nolan
collection
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
bloody comment below the win is going to
be chosen at random on september the
30th
so make sure you get involved if you're
going to support the channel and get to
see content early then please consider
clicking the joy button below
you can also come chat to us on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you being the best i've been definition
i'll see you next time take care
peace
you